oh what you got there rick this is
my ref rolodex all the greats are in
here
me
yeah yeah
[Music]
wow get those ready to layer onto this
cause i finished a new song last night
it's my most ambitious one yet
huh hey ray put me through the board
oh yeah sure okay right out the gate
siri pau's leg david hooked to my phone
now oh uh ray ray let's do uh
ethereal melancholy for the vocals so
you can really crank the stank on cue
fader four thank you buddy okay
according to the oxford english
dictionary the word set has the most
meanings
430
and this song uses
all of
[Music]
an them here do you probably set
don't take the first ring set with shiny
stones there's that word set won't leave
her alone
age 22 set her luggage down set sail and
run run run this town
skyscraper set her soul on fire her
height set
higher and higher
oh boy she thought that she was sad with
her
life tools but the city changed the mood
game said match
[Music]
set the prisoners free
when the sun sets blue over alpha
centauri
we'll be setting course for the colony
life still feels like it's just begun
but with her hair said one last time
she says
game
set
match
[Music]
i counted
370. i think i missed a few but siri
resume leg
[Music]
[Music]